Hi everyone!
Thanks for joining us,
this is -
what is it called?
The other show.
(upbeat electronic music)
Hey everyone,
thanks for joining us
on The other show,
today we're talking
about episode six,
and we're here with
Helene and Drew as always,
and Molly Shannon who plays Pat!
[Molly] Hello, so
happy to be here.
(all laughing)
this is so,
this is like my dream
of being an actress,
like, on a show -
What do you mean?
With a couch,
talking. (all laugh)
[Sarah] That's why
you got into this.
Yeah, kind of.
[Sarah] To sit on a couch.
(all laugh)
Guess who's going to be
on Watch What Happens Live?
I love my Year of Yes!
Was it weird to, like,
shoot Watch What Happens
Live in character?
Or no.
Ummm,
that was a little weird,
[Chris] Yeah.
It's interesting,
because I've hardly
ever done that,
[Chris] Yeah.
So it's very strange,
cause in real life I
get nervous as myself,
if I do a talk show,
that does feel strange,
cause you're not yourself,
[Chris] Yeah.
So you don't feel as nervous.
And you're sitting
next to Patrick Wilson,
playing himself,
(Sarah laughs)
but you're in character?
It's bizarre!
So weird!
He was really nice.
Hi, um,
I'm looking to get jacked, fast.
Do you have a gym membership?
No, uh,
but it's kind of an emergency,
I'm going to be the bartender
on Watch What Happens Live,
cause, just -
it's good to be seen,
Okay, yeah, no, totally,
I did that last week.
You've been on Watch
What Happens Live, too,
but as the bartender, right?
Yes -
You have?
Yes!
What?
But you weren't
wearing clothes.
He was stripping!
I was wearing clothes,
I had, like, on a jacket,
like buttoned up to my neck,
like, I was like (yells softly).
I could not remember
that Guildenstern,
Rosencrantz and
Guildenstern line,
because I was so nervous, like,
it was just like
sense memory of being
behind the bartender
like thing again,
I was like oh,
I'm nervous again!
(all laughing)
It was very funny,
cause even in between takes,
when people would be talking,
or giving notes or something,
you were always just
standing back there,
by yourself in a little bow tie,
just still there.
(all laughing)
Yeah, I was trying
to conserve warmth,
and also, like, you had said,
like, hey, we don't
have much time in there,
so any time we're in between,
just like
No, I wasn't rushing
the actors,
We had all the time
in the world
You had all
the time in the world!
How you doing,
you excited?
Oh, I'm so nervous
I could barf!
I just hope I don't
mess up tonight.
Don't be nervous,
you literally can't mess
up Watch What Happens Live.
Molly, your character
in particular,
is like super
starstruck, I guess,
like, are there people,
to this day that
you, Molly Shannon,
would still be
starstruck around? Or no.
Yes. Definitely.
There are?
Oh yeah!
That you haven't met,
or you've met them
and still like...
I met them and I
still feel starstruck.
[Chris] Who?
Like, Angelina Jolie.
And you've met her?
(all laughing)
[Helene] You've met Angelina!
Every time you're around
Angelina you're starstruck.
I get starstruck
for Housewives, too,
like I said, like,
[Chris] Yes,
I bumped into
[Chris] Absolutely.
Shannon Beador
at the LAX Airport,
and I was like (gasp loudly),
it's like the gates opened up,
(laughing)
like I get very excited!
I'm obviously a big Molly fan,
Yeah,
And I was like,
during the pilot
when we were filming,
I was like, if it
ever looks like
the person acting
across from Molly
is just a big fan of hers,
(laughing)
and is smiling huge,
just tell me,
(Molly laughing)
cause I felt like I was
just kind of like...
♪ Dance all day,
♪ Dance all night,
♪ Dance until we
don't smell right, ♪
♪ Dance until we,
♪ Stink, stink,
stink, stink... ♪
Yeah, I, uh,
I was told
that there would be dancing
in this music video,
and they were like,
there's going to be a rehearsal,
and it sort of
sounded super casual,
and so I was like, um,
okay so, I guess I have
to learn this dance,
and they weren't really
telling me the time,
they made it seem like it
was going to be nothing,
and I showed up for the
rehearsal and I was like,
(gasps loudly) this is real!
And then all of the girls
that did that music video,
all of the dancers are so good,
Yeah, they're amazing
And I was like, God,
all of you guys are so good,
I feel like I'm in
a Beyonce video,
and Cat, the
choreographer, went,
Oh, these girls do
dance for Beyonce!
And I was like (groans),
and I walked out one door
of the rehearsal room,
and like, came back in the
other door and was like,
I'm ready to start again.
Did it make you
sad that you weren't
still dancing, Brookie?
Um, no, actually,
I like what I'm doing.
Plus, if I had kept dancing,
I'd be starting
over now anyways,
so, I guess in some
ways I got a head start.
That's beautiful.
Thanks, Mom.
No, I mean the top
that I'm wearing.
I really am like Pat.
Let's be honest,
Are you?
No!
Like, 10%?
Values,
20%?
Values?
Values.
(laughing)
Yeah.
Values? (laughing)
What are Pat's values?
Family?
Family.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and spirituality.
Yeah.
I think I was going to say,
just the way she's positive
about life and open,
Yeah.
I feel like that too,
I try to, I think I'm like that.
[Chris] Yeah.
I relate to her.
We talked about that
in the writers room,
that we like about
your character,
or hopefully what we
were trying to do was
not have her be
like a stage mom.
It's just sort of like, sure,
I love my son, and
everyone in America
is saying they love him too,
so I guess I love America,
(all laughing)
this is great, like, yes,
just saying yes to things.
Has anyone done a Year of Yes?
Or like, made a conscious
effort to be like,
this year I'm going for it.
I think I do,
like, every January,
and then by like, February 2nd,
I'm like, I can't
remember, I don't know.
Yeah, I was going to try
to be more positive in 2018,
and I made it to
like, May. (laughs)
That's when we started
shooting! (all laughing)
Mom, why did you say
dad died of cancer?
What do you mean?
That's what we
decided to tell Chase.
Yeah, Chase,
not the whole viewing audience
of Watch What Happens.
Well, I just figured,
Chase is going to be
watching it later, so...
Did I mess up?
Just in general, I
love the idea of a woman,
this isn't so much
me cause I'm married,
but I love a woman having
a very happy chapter two,
where they, you know,
her husband passed away,
but she's really like alive,
and so full without,
kind of a nice chapter
two at a nice age,
I just think that's
so true to life,
and I see a lot of women
really happy that way,
[All] Yeah
Kind of reinventing
themselves maybe
after a divorce,
or a death of a spouse,
in a very positive way.
I just love that
Well, Molly, thank
you for being here!
It's my pleasure!
Thank you for telling
us about Celebrity.